hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday October 11th 2010 how the hell
are you are you doing good
well that's good um I had all this [ __ ]
that I wanted to talk about and then I
was looking at these [ __ ] emails and
right off the bat I got one from lo and
behold douchebag of the [ __ ] week
guys names Brad
of course his [ __ ] name's bread you
know what else would it Widow what a
mother and father named a douchebag baby
other than Brad
this is from Brad bill I was hoping that
I could find your podcast on iTunes yet
another week passes by where your fans
cannot listen to your show no problem
with that right to there then he goes
you might want to make that a priority
sometime too that can just [ __ ] see
his bare feet and his [ __ ] penny
loafers what are you leaning on my
cubicle you [ __ ] [ __ ] really do I
really want to make that a priority you
dumb [ __ ] you don't think I'm not trying
to contact iTunes they don't have a
[ __ ] person who answers their phones
they ignore my goddamn emails what am I
supposed to do go down to Main Street
write down on Main Street to the [ __ ]
mom-and-pop [ __ ] mr. mrs. iTunes
store it doesn't exist you douche you
might want to make that a priority
[ __ ] soon I want to slap you right in
your privileged [ __ ] Connecticut white
face and I don't give a [ __ ] if you're
not white and even not from Connecticut
cuz you should be with that [ __ ] tone
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] to the weak bread go
[ __ ] yourself alright I'm trying to get
this thing back up on iTunes they're not
responding to me what am I supposed to
do they don't have a location this is
the exact [ __ ] I've been [ __ ] trying
to tell you guys about it starts with
those goddamn automated machines down at
the [ __ ] grocery store you're siding
with the [ __ ] robots some of that
made sense you know it did seriously
this is the future this is what a store
is going to be you're not gonna be able
to get in contact with any
buddy you're gonna have a problem and
you can basically go [ __ ] yourself and
then some other [ __ ] nerd whose only
job is gonna be [ __ ] grease the elbow
with a [ __ ] robot that took his job
is gonna send me an email tell me that I
need to make something a priority why
don't you [ __ ] yourself buddy then why
don't you why don't you make that a
priority sometime soon all right what a
[ __ ] I swear to god you are you might
want to make that a priority sometime
soon oh the [ __ ] stuffed shirt
[ __ ] hang you by your goddamn tie
Brad you [ __ ] [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself
I'm glad you told all your friends to
listen to it and now they can't huh
what's that [ __ ] with you and your
goddamn ego do you have a position at
work little [ __ ] corner office Brad
[ __ ] [ __ ] telling me I need
breathing you might want to make that a
priority once you tell me something
[ __ ] else obvious all right there you
go there's your head of steam for the
week douche bag of the week good old
bread I had no idea really if it wasn't
on iTunes and people couldn't download
it anymore
like that would present some sort of a
problem and drop my listenership you
think I don't realize that Brad you
[ __ ] dick I'm sorry guys this is
really [ __ ] angry that guy just
really set me off with it it devs the
exact [ __ ] reason why it became a
goddamn comedian cuz I don't want to
ever be in a position where some douche
comes over leans over into my life and
tells me what I might want to make a
[ __ ] priority you condescending [ __ ]
what what kind of a mouse of a woman did
you marry
she's probably downstairs right now
making a voodoo doll of you and your
[ __ ] Dockers you fat gut hanging out
you one of those guys huh
you always got to wear the sport coat
and no one knows how fat you are until
til they have the office [ __ ] let's
go play frisbee party and then you show
up with your [ __ ] man tits heart
disease buddy that's what I wish on you
go [ __ ] yourself listen to another
podcast you might want to make that a
priority
oh Jesus